All right, so let me show you some examples on the real chat.
So let's suppose that we are in a downtrend
and then we are looking to identify market structure breaks.
Okay, we are looking for market structure breaks.
Okay, so as you can see, price made a new lower low,
lower high, lower low, lower high, lower low, lower high,
lower low, lower high, and then lower low,
made another lower high,
then we made a lower low once again.
So now this type of market structure
is considered to be a market structure break, okay?
When price continuously makes new lower lows
and the trend is continuing,
that is considered to be a market structure break, okay?
So as you can see, right around this level,
price broke through it,
that is considered to be market structure break,
then we pull it back and then price broke through
that previous low low,
and you can see that this is considered
to be market structure break as well.
Now what is market structure shift?
So as you can see that we were continuously making
lower lows, lower highs, lower lows, lower highs,
but then we made a higher high, higher low, and higher high.
Now this is considered to be,
now this break right around here,
when price breaks through this level,
which is the previous low,
we made a lower low, lower high,
lower low, lower high, then lower low,
and then price reversed,
breaking the previous low of the bearish trend.
Now this is considered to be a market structure shift.
Very, very easy guys.
I hope you understood what I thought you guys.
So this is considered to be market structure shift.
So I hope this is clear,
and as you can see,
the price has continued up for a bit,
but then it made another, as you can see,
price made another market structure shift.
So we made a higher high, higher low, higher high,
and then we created this lower low, lower high,
and then lower low, lower high, lower low.
Okay, so you can see how we identified the markets.
Now this was, this move right here,
when price broke this level,
then it is considered be a market structure shift.
So I hope this is clear now,
and I'll see you guys in the next video.